Shure: 不对我看剧
Shure: No, I'm watching a show.
Shure: 不是
Shure: No.
Shure: 岂不是把所有手里边这个都没录上
Shure: Doesn't that mean we didn't record any of this?
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Huh?
Shure: 知道现在在干嘛吗
Shure: Do you know what we're doing now?
Shure: 杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Shure: 猜猜我在干嘛
Shure: Guess what I'm doing?
Shure: 这部叫什么这部叫
Shure: What's this called, this is called...
Shure: 改刀
Shure: Knife skills.
Shure: 蒙对个刀字
Shure: Guess the word "knife".
Katrina: 有啥需要帮忙的吗
Katrina: Do you need any help?
Shure: 发现就一个菜板
Shure: I just realized we only have one cutting board.
Shure: 哎呦忘买百事可乐了
Shure: Oh no, I forgot to buy Pepsi.
Shure: 等一会再需要你
Shure: I'll need your help later.
Katrina: ok
Shure: 完了J人上去了
Shure: Oh no, I hooked someone.
Shure: 那什么排骨在哪
Shure: Where are the ribs?
Katrina: 这个芍药开的好大呀
Shure: 帮我倒点材料吧
Shure: Help me pour some ingredients.
Katrina: 嗯
Shure: 啊啊我先把洋葱切好
Shure: Ah, let me chop the onions first.
Katrina: 把什么
Shure: 帮我把洋葱拿一下
Shure: Help me get the onions.
Katrina: 洋葱
Katrina: Onions?
Katrina: 就生蚝生蚝不要放冰箱
Katrina: Don't put the oysters in the fridge.
Shure: 然后一会我让你倒什么你就倒
Shure: Then later, whatever I ask you to pour, just pour it.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Shure: 咱有一次性手套啥的吗
Shure: Do we have any disposable gloves?
Katrina: 哎今天吃披萨应该有多的吧
Katrina: Hey, we should have some left from today's pizza.
Katrina: 这是不是哎
Katrina: Is this it? Hey...
Shure: 要没有的话我就
Shure: If not, then I...
Katrina: 他是这种手套
Katrina: It's these gloves.
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
Katrina: 橡胶的
Katrina: Rubber ones.
Shure: 也行其实拿一会的先先拿
Shure: That's fine, actually. Just grab them for now.
Katrina: 我洗蓝莓算了
Katrina: 狂吃水果
Katrina: Eating a lot of fruit.
Katrina: 你平时在家做饭做的多吗
Katrina: Do you cook a lot at home?
Shure: 还好
Shure: It's alright.
Shure: 怎么着饿不死自个
Shure: Enough to not starve myself.
Shure: 你怎么拆了
Shure: Why did you open it?
Shure: 拆这个蓝莓
Shure: Open the blueberries.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Shure: 我刚才好像没一下碰着
Shure: I think I missed it just now.
Katrina: 馋了
Katrina: I'm craving it.
Shure: 来吧我把我手套戴上
Shure: Come on, I'll put on my gloves.
Katrina: 呀真的没坏吧这是
Katrina: Oh no, is it really not broken?
Shure: 怕你们嫌弃我
Shure: I'm afraid you'll dislike it.
Katrina: 都有现成吃还敢嫌弃
Katrina: There's ready-made food, no one would dislike that.
Katrina: 怎敢造次
Katrina: How could I complain?
Katrina: 美美火锅
Katrina: Delicious hotpot.
Shure: 这是大鲍梅是吗
Shure: Is this a big abalone?
Shure: 怎么戴不进去
Shure: Why can't I put it on?
Shure: 这手套是戴反了吧
Shure: These gloves are inside out.
Shure: 戴反了
Shure: Inside out.
Katrina: 你在搞笑
Katrina: Are you joking?
Shure: 花怎么这么难带
Shure: Why are they so hard to put on?
Shure: 冲点水呢
Shure: Rinse them with some water.
Katrina: 哼哼
Katrina: Hmph.
Shure: 不想带了
Shure: I don't want to wear them anymore.
Katrina: 我给你上去找找有没有那个一次性的
Katrina: I'll go find some disposable ones for you.
Shure: 没事没事
Shure: No, it's fine.
Shure: 带这就行
Shure: These will do.
Shure: 一会感动的哭了
Shure: I'll be moved to tears later.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: 你先把手里草莓放
Shure: Put down the strawberries first.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Shure: 先
Shure: First...
Katrina: 是很难哈
Katrina: It's really hard, huh?
Katrina: 首先大拇指跟小拇指位置是对
Katrina: First, the thumb and little finger should be in the right place.
Shure: 这个好带的好顺畅
Shure: This one fits smoothly.
Katrina: 现在他们那个剧组会来吗
Katrina: Will their crew come now?
Shure: 好像不会了没有了
Shure: Seems like they won't come anymore.
Katrina: OK那我们自己吃
Katrina: OK, then we'll eat by ourselves.
Shure: 呃
Shure: Uh...
Shure: 料酒啊不对
Shure: Cooking wine... no, wait.
Shure: 你先把我新新来的那个快递打开
Shure: First, open the new package I just got.
Shure: 那个
Shure: That one.
Katrina: 怎么还买矿泉水呢
Katrina: Why did you buy bottled water?
Katrina: 这有两个烧烤料
Katrina: There are two barbecue sauces here.
Shure: 对没错
Shure: Yes, exactly.
Shure: 就是这个
Shure: That's it.
Katrina: 然后呢
Katrina: And then?
Shure: 然后把那烧烤料这个扔冰箱
Shure: Then put the barbecue seasoning in the fridge.
Shure: 这是冰块冻的
Shure: These are frozen ice cubes.
Katrina: 这是冰块
Katrina: These are ice cubes.
Shure: 对对对忘了
Shure: Yeah, yeah, I forgot.
Shure: 差点直接丢里面得了
Shure: Almost just threw them in directly.
Katrina: 烧烤料怎么样
Katrina: How's the barbecue seasoning?
Katrina: 撒上面
Katrina: Sprinkle it on top.
Shure: 然后倒
Shure: Then pour it.
Katrina: 倒多少呀
Katrina: How much should I pour?
Shure: 我闻一下
Shure: Let me smell it.
Katrina: 哇好香啊
Katrina: Wow, it smells so good.
Shure: 就这个倒了
Shure: Just pour this.
Shure: 再倒
Shure: Pour some more.
Shure: 再倒点
Shure: Pour a bit more.
Shure: 然后
Shure: Then...
Shure: 鸡蛋打了一个
Shure: Crack an egg.
Katrina: 打鸡蛋
Katrina: Crack an egg?
Shure: 会会打不
Shure: Do you know how to crack it?
Katrina: 应该可以吧
Katrina: I think I can.
Shure: 打没打过呀
Shure: Have you cracked one before?
Katrina: 没怎么打过
Katrina: Not really.
Shure: 天当时只道是寻常没想到
Shure: Oh man, I thought it was routine, didn't expect that.
Shure: 给你表演个单手打蛋啊
Shure: Let me show you how to crack it with one hand.
Katrina: 再打几个
Katrina: Crack a few more.
Shure: 打一个就够了
Shure: One is enough.
Katrina: 为什么要打鸡蛋
Katrina: Why crack an egg?
Katrina: 就是让肉嫩一点吗
Katrina: To make the meat more tender?
Shure: 就是这个味
Shure: That's the flavor.
Shure: 对也算是嫩一点
Shure: Yeah, it also makes it a bit tender.
Shure: 然后那个料酒蚝油都拿出来
Shure: Then take out the cooking wine and oyster sauce.
Katrina: 料酒蚝油
Katrina: Cooking wine and oyster sauce.
Katrina: 料酒蚝油这
Katrina: Cooking wine and oyster sauce here.
Katrina: 这没开是不是
Katrina: This one isn't opened, right?
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh no.
Shure: 你过来你过来
Shure: Come here, come here.
Shure: 不用不用我教你
Shure: No need, I'll teach you.
Katrina: 怎么弄
Katrina: How do I do it?
Shure: 他应该有一个竖向的
Shure: There should be a vertical one.
Shure: 能掰一下吧
Shure: You can snap it open.
Shure: 对你能扣开吗
Shure: Can you open it?
Katrina: 料酒和什么
Katrina: Cooking wine and what?
Katrina: 蚝油是吗
Katrina: Oyster sauce, right?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Katrina: 蚝油放哪了
Katrina: Where's the oyster sauce?
Shure: 上面还有这个
Shure: There's more up here.
Shure: 给AI看看
Shure: Show it to the AI.
Shure: 人类最好用的工具牙
Shure: The most useful tool for humans is teeth.
Shure: 小虎牙不用白长了
Shure: Don't let those baby teeth go to waste.
Shure: 是
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 吧
Shure: Right.
Shure: 然后挤
Shure: Then squeeze.
Shure: 然后一会
Shure: Then wait a bit.
Shure: 这应该直接能挤吧
Shure: This should squeeze out directly, right?
Shure: 再挤点再来点
Shure: Squeeze a bit more, a bit more.
Shure: 好够了
Shure: Okay, that's enough.
Shure: 然后那个油
Shure: Then the oil.
Shure: 少倒点油
Shure: Pour a little oil.
Shure: 对玉米油这些
Shure: Yes, corn oil, these kinds.
Shure: 真是传的
Shure: It's really passed down.
Shure: 我妈传我的
Shure: My mom taught me this.
Katrina: 到时候我偷一下
Katrina: I'll sneak some next time.
Katrina: 还要
Katrina: Need more.
Shure: 呃少来一点
Shure: Uh, just a little bit.
Shure: 点
Shure: A bit.
Katrina: 那每一个肉都是这个流程
Katrina: So every piece of meat goes through this process?
Katrina: 可乐鸡翅吗
Katrina: Cola chicken wings?
Shure: 不可乐只是借个甜味
Shure: Not really, just for the sweetness.
Shure: 其实没有的时候用白糖也行
Shure: Actually, you can use sugar if you don't have any.
Shure: 但是一般都用百事可乐
Shure: But generally, we use Pepsi.
Katrina: 哈哈你要挑起百事与可可的战
Katrina: Haha, are you trying to start a Pepsi vs. Coke war?
Shure: 不是因为百事甜
Shure: No, because Pepsi is sweeter.
Shure: 平时我自个喝也喝可口
Shure: Normally, I drink Coke myself.
Shure: 他只配啊
Shure: It just matches better.
Shure: 不行这个不能
Shure: No, this can't...
Katrina: 争
Katrina: Argue.
Shure: 少少倒少倒
Shure: Pour a little, pour a little.
Shure: 再再来一点
Shure: More, more.
Shure: 哦够够
Shure: Oh, that's enough.
Shure: 然后那个孜然粉再倒一点
Shure: Then add a bit more cumin powder.
Shure: 看没眼前
Shure: Look, right in front of you.
Katrina: 洗刷刷洗刷刷
Katrina: Scrub scrub scrub.
Shure: 哎这不是
Shure: Hey, isn't this...
Shure: 这不是孜然粉那个
Shure: Isn't this cumin powder?
Shure: 烧烤料其实可以再来一点  闻一下
Shure: We could actually add a bit more BBQ seasoning. Smell it.
Katrina: 再来一点
Katrina: Add a bit more.
Katrina: 还再买一点
Katrina: And buy a bit more.
Jake:敲不开你帮我
Jake: Can't open it, can you help me?
Jake:再帮我敲敲
Jake: Help me knock it open again.
Shure: 对拉开
Shure: Yes, pull it open.
Shure: 然后然后然后直接用那大口也倒就行
Shure: Then, then, then just pour it directly using the big opening.
Shure: 把那边机子摁上OK好
Shure: Press the machine over there, OK, good.
Shure: 我觉得应该是在
Shure: I think it should be...
Shure: 再倒点
Shure: Pour a bit more.
Katrina: 烤料要再来点吗
Katrina: Need more BBQ seasoning?
Shure: 好了啊
Shure: Alright, done.
Shure: 不是再来一下你这
Shure: Add some more, will you?
Shure: 没了是吗
Shure: Is it finished?
Shure: 这好好这回绝对够了
Shure: This time, it's definitely enough.
Katrina: 怕太咸
Katrina: Afraid it'll be too salty.
Katrina: 太咸了就喝可乐
Katrina: If it's too salty, just drink cola.
Shure: 我在给他们做按摩做马杀鸡闻闻
Shure: I'm giving them massages, doing Thai massage, smell it.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina: 戴着手套特别像给鸡做手术呢
Katrina: Wearing gloves, it really looks like I'm doing surgery on the chicken.
Katrina: 特别搞笑
Katrina: It's so funny.
Shure: 一闻就不吱声
Shure: It stops making noise as soon as you smell it.
Shure: 这个就算腌好了
Shure: This is marinated now.
Shure: 然后腌下一个
Shure: Now to marinate the next one.
Katrina: 要腌大概多久呀
Katrina: How long does it need to marinate?
Shure: 这个腌其实腌一会就行
Shure: This actually just needs to marinate for a bit.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Shure: 立即烤其实也没问题
Shure: Grilling it right away is fine too.
Shure: 这个可以放最后烤
Shure: This can be grilled last.
Katrina: 嗯好香啊
Katrina: Hmm, smells so good.
Katrina: 你可以去开烤肉店哎
Katrina: You could open a BBQ restaurant.
Shure: 是吧
Shure: Right?
Katrina: 开上连锁的我加盟
Katrina: Open a chain, and I'll join.
Shure: 没有的话我只能拿这个锅当那什么
Shure: If there's none, I'll have to use this pot.
Katrina: 塑料盆不合适
Katrina: The plastic basin isn't suitable.
Shure: 这主要别的就看着有点寒碜
Shure: Mainly, the others look a bit shabby.
Shure: 而且看起来就像洗衣服那种
Shure: And it looks like laundry or something.
Shure: 给人没食欲你懂吗
Shure: It just looks unappetizing, you know?
Katrina: 吧
Katrina: Right.
Shure: 你想想动动你聪明的小脑瓜
Shure: Think about it, use your smart little brain.
Shure: 最好是铁的
Shure: It should be iron.
Shure: 不行不行不行
Shure: No, no, no.
Shure: 就跟那个要一样的那种
Shure: It should be like that one.
Shure: 最起码是个山兜
Shure: At least it should be a mountain bag.
Shure: 的
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina: 蛋糕不行
Katrina: Cake won't do.
Katrina: 蛋糕会串味
Katrina: Cake will mix flavors.
Katrina: 对呀哦不对
Katrina: Yeah, oh wait.
Katrina: 这也是空有空
Katrina: This is also empty, just empty.
Shure: 没有不行就还这个吧还这个
Shure: If it doesn't work, just go back to this one, let's stick to this.
Katrina: 这你对他有哪里不满意
Katrina: What don't you like about this one?
Shure: 沉
Shure: Heavy.
Shure: 这好像那下扔鱼的时候手链撞了
Shure: When I threw the fish, the bracelet hit me.
Shure: 这特疼
Shure: It hurt a lot.
Katrina: 为什么不戴手套拆呢
Katrina: Why don't you wear gloves to open it?
Shure: 哦有道理啊
Shure: Oh, that's a good idea.
Shure: 不用摘啊
Shure: No need to take them off.
Shure: 帮我拿充电宝
Shure: Help me get the power bank.
Shure: 给我iPad插电
Shure: Plug in my iPad.
Shure: 哈哈帮我拿iPad拿充电宝
Shure: Haha, help me get the iPad and the power bank.
Shure: 给我iPad插个电
Shure: Plug in my iPad.
Katrina: iPad哪一口
Katrina: Which port for the iPad?
Katrina: 大口小口
Katrina: Big port or small port?
Katrina: 这是哪个口
Shure: C口C口
Shure: 哪个群
Shure: Which group?
Katrina: 什么寒
Katrina: What cold?
Katrina: 吃水果了
Katrina: Time for fruit.
Lucia: 等我把这个开了再去洗个手
Lucia: Let me finish this and then I'll wash my hands.
Lucia: 然后嗯好了
Lucia: Then, okay.
Shure: 来
Shure: Come on.
Katrina: 到
Shure: 还是鸡蛋
Shure: Still eggs.
Shure: 肉腌好了抽出去闻闻
Shure: The meat is marinated, take it out and smell it.
Katrina: 我来
Katrina: I'll do it.
Shure: nice
Shure: nice.
Shure: 你还是用俩手吧先
Shure: Use both hands first.
Katrina: 什么叫用俩手
Katrina: What do you mean by using two hands?
Katrina: 不会用俩手
Katrina: I can't use two hands.
Shure: 对对对然后
Shure: Yeah, yeah, and then...
Shure: OK OK
Shure: OK, OK.
Shure: 你又掌握了一个人生的新技能
Shure: You've just learned a new life skill.
Katrina: 是的
Katrina: Yes.
Shure: 然后记得搁什么了吗
Shure: And do you remember what to add?
Shure: 那烧烤料
Shure: That barbecue seasoning.
Katrina: 烧烤粉你这让我学过去了啊
Katrina: Barbecue powder, you've taught me well.
Katrina: 独家秘方
Katrina: A secret recipe.
Shure: 都到这这都到了
Shure: It's all here, it's all here.
Shure: 好
Shure: Good.
Shure: 这头道引荐这样
Shure: This introduction, like this...
Shure: 然后库库都到里
Jake:在楼上走走
Jake: Walk around upstairs.
Jake:我们上楼
Jake: We're going upstairs.
Shure: 然后那个
Jake:我们上楼执行任务
Jake: We're going upstairs to carry out the mission.
Shure: 孜然粉
Shure: Cumin powder.
Katrina: 咖啡粉不对不对说错了
Shure: 孜然粉就你面前哪个
Shure: The cumin powder is right in front of you.
Shure: 好好好够了够了
Katrina: 烧烤孜然耗油料酒
Shure: 那圆葱忘切了你会切圆葱吗
Katrina: 葱吗
Katrina: 这样切竖着切下去
Katrina: Cut it vertically like this.
Shure: 把它放平
Shure: Lay it flat.
Katrina: 这样
Katrina: Like this.
Shure: 对然后
Shure: Yeah, and then...
Katrina: 这样切
Katrina: Cut like this.
Shure: 抵住然后一条一条切对
Shure: Hold it down and cut it into strips, right.
Katrina: 那应该还行吧
Katrina: That should be fine, right?
Shure: 我来我来我来
Shure: I'll do it, I'll do it, I'll do it.
Katrina: 我来我来我来
Katrina: I'll do it, I'll do it, I'll do it.
Shure: 不用切那么细
Shure: No need to cut it so thin.
Katrina: 这得这个得锻炼一下
Katrina: This needs to be practiced a bit.
Shure: 稍微粗点就行
Shure: Just cut it a bit thicker.
Katrina: 要不然以后我妈担心我没法活下去
Katrina: Otherwise, my mom would worry, and I wouldn't survive.
Katrina: 但是我确实基本不做
Katrina: But I really don't do it often.
Shure: 男朋友不得
Shure: No boyfriend?
Katrina: 找个男朋友会做饭就行
Katrina: Finding a boyfriend who can cook is fine.
Katrina: 我妈说会做饭哪瞧得上你呀
Katrina: My mom says, "Who would want someone who can cook?"
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 我吗真的是
Jake:凭什么呀
Jake: Why would that be?
Katrina: 这个怎么切呀
Katrina: 我的手脏了
Katrina: My hands are dirty.
Shure: 一会再洗一下
Shure: Wash them again later.
Shure: 或者现在洗也行
Shure: Or you can wash them now.
Katrina: 嗯料酒加了蚝油没加
Katrina: Yeah, I added cooking wine but not oyster sauce.
Shure: 然后
Shure: Then...
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Katrina: 那这腌其实也挺快
Shure: 好可以了
Shure: Okay, that's fine.
Shure: 再再来点好
Shure: Let's add a bit more.
Katrina: 耗油料酒
Shure: 还差啥
Shure: What else is missing?
Katrina: 两个粉
Katrina: 等一下我想一下可乐
Shure: 聪明啊一点就透了
Shure: Smart, you got it right away.
Katrina: 直接偷学过去了
Shure: 倒啊
Shure: 好好好再来点
Shure: OK可以了
Shure: 刚刚芝麻忘放了
Katrina: 芝麻和辣椒面吗
Katrina: Sesame and chili powder?
Shure: 辣椒面不用放芝麻放就行
Shure: No need for chili powder, just add sesame.
Katrina: 刚刚那没放
Katrina: That wasn't added.
Katrina: 要补充进去吗
Katrina: Should we add it in?
Shure: 要的
Shure: 好好
Jake:饱和了
Jake: It's saturated.
Shure: 再把那个拿过来吧
Shure: Bring that over here.
Shure: 然后这个
Shure: And this one.
Jake:好的好大活
Jake: Okay, a big task.
Shure: 不知道咸淡有也放这里
Lucia: 有地放不这这
Lucia: Is there space here?
Katrina: 你觉得少点什么味吗
Katrina: Do you think it's missing some flavor?
Katrina: 像那个浣衣女
Katrina: Like that washerwoman.
Katrina: 山竹
Katrina: Mangosteen.
Katrina: 这要放冰箱吗
Katrina: Should this be put in the fridge?
Lucia: 对我也在想啊
Lucia: Yeah, I was thinking that too.
Lucia: 这个反正一会要哎好多水
Lucia: Since we need to bake it later, it's a lot of water.
Lucia: 这个一会要烤对吧
Lucia: We need to bake this later, right?
Lucia: 那应该不用放
Lucia: Then we shouldn't need to put it in the fridge.
Lucia: 我把山竹放下好了
Lucia: I'll put the mangosteen down.
Lucia: 咱别忘了还有这个
Lucia: Let's not forget we also have this.
Lucia: 然后还有土豆
Lucia: And we also have potatoes.
Katrina: 生蚝怎么做老师
Katrina: How do we cook the oysters, teacher?
Shure: 生蚝直接烤会
Shure: Just grill the oysters directly.
Jake:大家早上好啊来吧
Jake: Good morning everyone, let's get started.
Katrina: 不用对它清洗吗
Katrina: Don't we need to clean them?
Shure: 会撬开吗
Shure: Can you open them?
Shure: 撬他撬开就行
Shure: Just pry them open.
Katrina: 要对它进行清洗吗
Katrina: Do we need to wash them?
Shure: 对不用撬开就行
Shure: No need, just pry them open.
Katrina: 真的吗
Shure: 就是洗吧洗吧翘开
Shure: Just wash them and pry them open.
Lucia: 我们竟然还买了煎牛排好酷啊
Lucia: We even bought steak to fry, that's so cool!
Katrina: 两盆肉所有都放进来了
Shure: 需要腌的都放进来
Shure: Put everything that needs marinating in here.
Katrina: 嗯然后呢
Katrina: Hmm, then what?
Shure: 这些大概两斤多肉
Shure: This is about more than two pounds of meat.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Shure: 然后12个鸡翅
Shure: And 12 chicken wings.
Shure: 一斤不到一斤排骨
Shure: Less than a pound of ribs.
Katrina: 嗯然后呢
Katrina: Hmm, then what?
Alice:这是谁的水吗
Alice: Whose water is this?
Katrina: 没有这是外外卖买的是
Katrina: No, it was bought from outside.
Shure: 啊我
Shure: Ah, I...
Shure: 我为了配配那什么然后带的
Shure: I brought it to go with whatever.
Shure: 随便打开
Shure: Just open it.
Shure: 打开就行
Jake:我们做什么
Jake: What are we doing?
Alice:一个很有品位的水
Alice: It's a very tasteful water.
Jake:做什么芒果
Jake: What about mango?
Shure: 帮我拍个视频什么的谢谢你
Shure: Help me shoot a video or something, thanks.
Katrina: 要拍到脸吗
Katrina: Do you need to show the face?
Shure: 不用拍了脸拍了手就行
Shure: No need, just shoot the hands.
Katrina: ok
Alice:嗦芒果核
Lucia: 土豆是今天晚上吃的吧同志们
Lucia: Potatoes are for dinner tonight, right folks?
Jake:是是吧烤土豆
Jake: Yes, roasted potatoes, right?
Shure: 这感觉料酒可以再倒一点对
Shure: I think we can add a bit more cooking wine
Lucia: 是的那我就把它拆开了
Lucia: Okay, I'll unwrap it
Jake:拆吧
Jake: Go ahead
Lucia: 这个可以用来暂时性的放一下
Lucia: This can be used to hold it for now
Alice:酸死了这个
Alice: This is so sour
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay
Katrina: 那个串的话就直接烤就行是吧
Alice:你再给他做马杀鸡
Alice: You're giving it a massage again
Katrina: 说独家秘方
Katrina: Tell us the secret recipe
Katrina: 敬请期待
Katrina: Stay tuned
Alice:独家秘方
Alice: Secret recipe
Alice:咋调的呀
Alice: How do you make it?
Katrina: 他妈祖传的
Katrina: It's a family heirloom
Jake:始于秦始皇时期哪一年
Jake: From which year during the Qin Shi Huang period?
Katrina: 哈哈哈终于修硕
Shure: 不多
Shure: Not much
Alice:公元前多少年
Alice: Which year B.C.?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahaha
Jake:终于修硕
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈他妈的
Shure: Hahaha damn it
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈啊
Lucia: Hahahahahaha
Shure: 你这话我跟你讲
Shure: You know what
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Shure: 哈哈哈祖传
Shure: Hahaha a family heirloom
Shure: 然后终于修硕是吧
Shure: 怎么我这边就
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Alice:意思是无出其右了
Alice: It means no one can surpass you
Lucia: 意思是
Lucia: It means
Jake:发扬发扬光大
Jake: Glorify and enhance it
Alice:知道没有人能超越你了
Alice: Knowing no one can surpass you
Shure: 知道没有人超越
Shure: Knowing no one surpasses you
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Jake:就是变化巨大
Jake: It's a huge change
Jake:这已经不算了
Jake: This doesn't count anymore.
Alice:就后面后来者再没有人能够超过你了
Alice: No one after you can surpass you now.
Jake:独树一帜
Jake: Unique and unmatched.
Shure: OK太牛逼了
Katrina: 新的流派
Katrina: A new style.